this is a production of Cornell
University
so greetings everybody my name is Dean
I've been working with a combination of
USDA AG Research Service and US
Geological Survey in the Chesapeake Bay
for about 12 years now finished my PhD
up at Cornell 12 years ago and headed on
down and started working on remote
sensing at winter cover crops so I
really appreciate this kind of a
conference because it allows the folks
who have got their fingers in the dirt
doing field experiments to interact with
kind of the big picture of what's
happening in the landscape with
implementation trends and we've been
working in a few different states to try
to work those things out so looking
forward to the interactions have a whole
slew of partners working with soil
conservation districts on project in New
York I'll be talking about upper
Susquehanna a project with serdika and
Pennsylvania and a lot of partnership
with Marin Department of Ag I work for
USGS so whenever you see the disclaimer
it means it hasn't gone through peer
review yet Chesapeake Bay Brian just
gave us a nice look at it water quality
being the primary issue and so winter
cover crops although you know how many
benefits they have really from a
Chesapeake Bay Program perspective its
nutrient and sediment reduction right so
provide cover over the soil surface to
reduce sediment loss and sequester
nitrogen and living biomass to keep it
green over the winter and reduce
nitrogen losses and so it's really
promoted by a combination of incentives
particularly in Maryland or through NRCS
regulation for example highly erodible
land you can plant a cover crop the new
earth can beat your t factor for your
erosion prevention through extension so
just good sense farmers talking to each
other working on soil health and and
economic benefits of winter cover crops
what you see in a state like Maryland
where there incentivization for
different programs is on performed on
farm performance is highly variable so
going from upper left which is probably
a rye crop planted with dairy manure
getting a nice thick biomass down to an
aerial seeded field that was cost shared
by the farmers and happened to fail that
year aerial seeding on a high residue
situation with poor rainfall that year
got zero biomass so that's the
environment we're working in and we're
trying to take a perspective we're
combining remote sensing satellite
imagery airborne imagery of measuring
vegetation on the soil surface combined
with collaboration with ongoing
Extension programs so knowledge of where
the fields are in Maryland what's going
on on them or other data is in other
states so we're we're thinking with this
toolkit we can really start quantifying
the environmental benefits of cover
crops
one of our main tools is satellite
imagery on the left you see a Landsat
image of the entire Eastern Shore set
within that Talbot County one of our
focus areas with some smaller imagery
spot that I obtained through US
Geological Survey so really every image
is a snapshot in time we tried to
collect imagery around December January
when the crops have gone dormant for the
winter and then again come back in April
or so to look at springtime growth
before it's terminated in the spring
you
if you look at the soil surface through
a satellite which sees infrared as well
as our visible bands you can see
vegetation pretty clearly so the bright
red here is reflectance in the
near-infrared so the redder fields have
higher biomass you can see pine trees
here having a high biomass you can see a
bear field and then various degrees of
vegetation cover within the farm
landscape
if you take a particular farm and this
is a collaborating farm I work on then
you can start really thinking about crop
rotations and you can think about
management here in Maryland we have a
lot of center pivot irrigation so you
can see fields chopped up with crop
rotations and then through collaboration
we obtain access to knowledge of what's
going on in these fields so this farm is
enrolled most of its land in cover crop
program they grow a lot of barley so any
field outlined in yellow is barley field
so for a particular field we might know
that is barley planted in two and a half
bushels a hectare using a no-till drill
planted on September 14th following corn
so a lot of information about what's
going on on that field with that cover
crop and then we can put a remote
sensing measurement to them and say that
management resulted in six hundred and
seventy kilograms per hectare pounds per
acre of biomass for example right and
then we do feel the same thing to back
that up so that's our general strategy
we collaborate with soil conservation
districts make it up to a lot of farms
to click the field sampling data that
Brian was talking about and then try to
promote adaptive management giving
information about what's going on on the
different fields so I like saying we
have two different strategies in a state
like Pennsylvania or New York where we
don't have access to knowledge of what's
going on the fields we use public
datasets so we're using satellite
imagery look at ground cover we're using
the cropland data layer to look at crop
type of the previous summer and then
we're combining those to look at say
what's the ground cover on corn fields
and Cayuga County New York right the
first work here's an example back in
talbot of an image that's been shaded
with the vegetation index or brighter
colors here as bear fields darker is
more vegetation we think about threshold
and
different biomass categories looking at
really minimum low medium high biomass
with corresponding groundcovers
thresholds and then we can translate our
image of the landscape into looking at
where the bare fields where the high
vegetation fields are then we combine
that with the cropland data layer if
you're not familiar with this this is a
USDA Nass product available 2008 to
present and they use imagery analysis to
look at crop rotation so here mainly
corn and soybean and wheat fields grown
in this county so by combining those we
can develop say a map of all of the corn
fields in Talbot County including the
low biomass medium and high biomass
fields just looking at vegetation in the
landscape by crop type and we've
developed a tool that will take the 10
top land uses in a county it will
calculate the area of corn six and a
half percent of the county's corn and
then looking at these biomass categories
so 50% of the corn fields have very
little biomass 30% 28% a little bit of
biomass though this amount 13% medium
and 9% high biomass right so somewhat
arbitrary where we said those points but
we use calibration data to try to get it
some environmental thresholds you can
look at it's similar patterns for
soybeans or for other crops in the
watershed and this is an example right
so by combining these data sets we're
looking at Talbot County Maryland we're
looking at 2008 through 213 from the
cropland data there we can see that the
acres of corn land have stayed fairly
stable with a little bump in 2010 we can
look at cover crop this is just numbered
fields not acres sorry this is number of
fields this is cover crop following corn
so 50
five percent of corn fields were planted
to cover crops under the subsidy program
you can see between 28 and 2013 that
number climb to 80% Maryland cover crop
subsidies increasing over time 80% of
corn land in this particular County in
2013 by higher than 56 80 on corn fields
other 56 overall crops well that's what
this bottom graph is all about right so
this is just the number of fields
enrollment program this is the
performance that's a nice fine
distinction of when a farmer got
enrolled in the program and that would
be really interesting to see if the
farmers I've not thought about looking
at that what we can look at is within
each of these corn cover crop fields
what's going on and you can see in 2009
the brown is minimal biomass the dark
green is high biomass and you can see
over this time we have shifted this is
all cornfields in the county right and
so as the cover crops have gone up we've
shifted towards a lot more biomass right
so this is one example of an announced
as you can do and it kind of using this
toolkit I did this for five counties in
Pennsylvania and collaboration with
sword Waker we published this a couple
years ago so I'll run through it real
quick but basically looking at these
counties they had a program called
without carrot or stick so not using
incentives but really just the farmers
trying to promote silage cover crops
following corn silage harvest and they
were very active in the landscape from
tending to a twenty ten to twelve and so
along with Seward and NIF with funding
we started thinking about well can we
see changes
their extension looking at the four
counties you can see the crop type
distribution and just get them straight
to the results for years and Berks in
York County you can see percentage of
bare soil decrease from 75 percent to
around 50 percent over that same time
period Lancaster and Lebanon have a
higher intensity of cover cropping and
varicella decreasing from 50 to 25
percent within these we saw some really
clear trends over time we didn't say
well let's make sure this isn't some bad
walk with warmer years over time and so
we did look as accumulated Grug degrees
by the time our images were collected
fairly stable some other analyses also
but really you know between 700 800 900
growing degrees over this time period
making us come to detecting increased
cover cropping
that's Pennsylvania just give me a
bird's-eye view some of the different
research we're doing so feel free to
look that up three counties in New York
just did that this summer so we're in
Cayuga County right now I did analysis
for K you last week it's not in this
graphic but looking at three counties in
New York looking at satellite imagery
what we find up here is that it's tough
to get but winter imagery it's either
cloudy or it's snowing a lot of the
winter comes over every 16 days so what
we found best for this analysis was a
spring time analysis every April in most
years we would get a clear image
so here's Seneca County we're down here
in Ithaca and between-the-legs is one of
the most productive grain areas of the
southern tier of New York you can see
crop type distribution a lot of alfalfa
corn and soybeans looking at the
satellite analysis for example of the
corn land within the county a lot of
corn land and here is a trend analysis
so a little bit different than our last
graphs but the colors are the same this
is corn going from 0 to 100% of corn
land so you can see not a lot of trend
over time in these four years we're
analyzing going from 73 60s 76 80% soil
without much of vegetation
you see 2009-10 had the most cover crop
well I'll say the something else they're
rotating into after corn all we know is
that there's wintertime vegetation
following corn this is a year with warm
temperatures in little high biomass but
no real trends over time looking at
Delaware County downstate near the cans
no reservoir a lot of just little
riverbank farms and finds up in the
hillsides not that much corn land
they've been extending cover crop or
extending conservation practices for
quite a while and we're seeing a higher
percent vegetation on these fields with
only 30 to 40%
vegetated fields but no real trends over
time here either
as a nuance the fields done they're very
small and I'm a little worried we're
getting mixed pixels with the edge of
the fields and they might not actually
have that option we're going posterity
to try to figure that out
third County Cortland County of broad
distribution of farmland and again we
had a better series of imagery here some
more years of analysis with clear
imagery in April and the heceta bouncing
around 66% 2010-11 operative cover crops
2014-15 was a terrible year for come
across late corn harvest wet fall very
few farmers able to plant cover crops
and we did see that that we really are
seeing in farming practices on cover
crop abduction not seeing any real
trends over coming so unlike
Pennsylvania we're finding some
consistent differences between counties
look at kind of the percent of corn
fields or other crop type fields that
are have winter vegetation following
their harvest but not really seeing any
clear tends over time so that's our
initial analysis for New York
I'm written up yet so that's what we do
in a state where we have the data for
all of the cover crop enrollment for the
entire state Brian was presenting some
of the trends from that data set and
then in particular counties we've worked
with the ages where they're actually
allow us to analyze the biomass and
they're moving toward doing that for the
entire state as part of the grant work
that we've done with Maryland so we're
working remote sensing analysis for the
entire state in the meantime we're
really focusing on Talbot County you
recall I was talking about you know
field boundaries per planted the
particular crops this farmer released
this information which is why I can show
it to you but I wouldn't show it for the
rest of the county what was going on
except an aggregate
form you can see the number of fields
planted to cover crops over time again
increasing over time and Talbot County
and we're able to really look at every
field and I already presented this type
of data the other thing we can get into
is really what are the agronomic factors
in the subsidy program that are leaning
towards variable success in cover crops
and you know what they are really from
your own knowledge of cover crops is
planting method its previous crop its
nitrogen soils weather planting date a
lot of these factors add up to determine
health of the cover crop performance of
the cover crops here's looking at
planting date right so Brian showed some
interesting data this is a different way
of looking at it this is the number of
fields planted within the early late
planting category so early is this green
line and that's planted before October
15th take-home message the only way
you're going to get more than 15
kilograms of nitrogen in a cover crop is
early and there's a big peak of late
planted fields that really so from my
point of view
let's give feedback to the farmer so
that we get more environmental benefit
from our subsidies this graph is the
accumulated biomass on this access so
this is about a ton per acre of thousand
kilograms per hectare and the gray is
growing degrees before December 31st so
if you plant September first
you get mmm a hundred grow or whatever I
don't know the number but you get this
many growing degrees and the grind
agrees to Windell over time right if you
plant November third very low growing
degree accumulation the Green Line is
the average biomass for every crop in
Talbot County planted on that date and
so you see a very tight relationship
between planting day growing and biomass
on em dan uary third gender six is when
this image would analysis it well you
see a little bump here in mid-october
that's we think associated with folks
who are planting wheat for harvest so
they're a lot more drilled cover crops
at that point but this is the type of
analysis you can get to you when you
start looking at all the cover crop
fields and Counting
you can also break it up by other
factors so looking at the differences in
species number of fields enrolled
biomass and nitrogen content this is
just for one year you look at this over
six years you throw my livers into the
factor it's a lot more complicated and
I'm looking forward to Brian's methods
to help kind of factors in our
enrollment data set you can see
difference in nitrogen content related
to planting day and then relating to
planting method with you know science of
proving the obvious you already know
that if you drill and get good seats or
contact you're going to get better
biomass and nitrogen accumulation than
if you're broadcasting by and large but
we're looking at this as a census of all
the fields in the county so it becomes a
fairly powerful tool
and then you can translate this again
into dollars per pound of nitrogen
sequestered and you can see that early
planted rise is a pretty good deal for
the taxpayers the compared to late
planted wheat and if you think about
that nitrogen being recycled back to the
field for the farmer better deal then
you can balance that out with incentive
payment covers the ground and then
saturate and you can't tell the
difference between 500 kilograms mass
and 3,000 right you can tell it up to
about a thousand up to by the ton per
acre you can that's okay we can measure
well through the critical environmental
threshold and it's similar with percent
ground cover between 0% and 80% ground
cover we can just stick with pretty well
and not do that we can just say so
you're absolutely right and we'll be
focusing on that with more analysis
just to find all kind of conclusions of
what we see in the landscape the very
high biomass fields tend to be cover
crop on a heavily more nutrient
application is it a great
environmentally we've sampled some
fields where they're still half of that
so there's a time for nutrient
management plant come in in combination
with to really solve these problems so
his green are always better you know I
think there's a happy medium from a
nitrogen leaching point of view we also
see a lot of nutrient limited cover crop
importantly not because of a late
planting or aerial seeding could be
early planted drilled dry still doing
poorly because there's no easy mmm the
cover crop purist might say well
fertilize it and you get more benefit is
there a lower threshold for cover crop
success again yes he want to achieve a
certain amount of biomass by certain
amount of time to have a good
environmental benefit but that nitrogen
limitation becomes a kind of a sticking
point and we cannot remote
how do we define success successful
strategies I think fitly the climate and
the farming system with good niches for
healthy productive cover crops that's
how we define success in terms of simple
nitrogen I was just talking about and
there may be some critical thresholds 4%
of soil coverage you know combination of
factors working in the in the
environment experimentation innovation
adoption and that getting back to carrot
or stick I think you know a combination
of incentive regulation and just playing
off farm to farm transfer and growing
the practice of healthy cover crops is
what's going to get us to the
environmental end points of a lot of
healthy cover crops in the landscape
remote sensing is one tool in the
toolbox it's kind of a broad brush I can
look at a field and say there's going on
but we have a good tool here so if
anybody's interested in your County or
looking at particular farms looking at
spatial variation and field thinking
about you know your your variability or
you're working with the sustainable AG
lab folks as they together come across
growth models combining the cover crop
growth models but the remote sensing
will be good further development that's
what I got
[Applause]
so for a few years we were going out
October December April on the same field
we were sampling nitrogen and you see a
fair amount of residual nitrogen you see
about half of it collected by the
covercraft and the other half lost below
the top foot and really by springtime
you've lost all your nitrogen from their
top foot food in our brown sandy soils
fairly high ranked ball in the
wintertime you lose the nitrogen under
the surface soil and feel we've also
seen evidence of the cover crops going
down and catching that pulse from deeper
soil I'm bringing it up where the amount
of nitrogen in a cover crop in the
spring time was more than the amount of
nitrogen in the top for the soil in
October from growing into the springs
awesome I think that the March 1st
cutoff date was historic from early
organization of the cover crop program
to feat bit of the farmers need and
they're basically saying well after
March 1st you can do where you want I
think it's up to the extension folks to
say they finally there's a real soil
health benefit from going longer maybe
don't need Maryland to pay there are
farmers who talked about ride getting
away from the spring and not know you
guys who are really I'm happy to bring
that type of information
Tamara London if we're looking at the
spring time then we look at that remote
sensing gets tricky in the spring
because certain fields get terminated I
really have to you can't look at the
whole landscape you have to start
looking at termination dates and follow
fields as they go from green to yellow
to brown to plant the green again with
the corn
that is your question and there's a lot
of mineralization happens in the
springtime they're not resisting I'm
sure they'll be open though look at
nitrogen content yeah the USGS we like
we've used them a little bit
experimentally I'm based out of Beltran
Research Station and we're within the DC
no-fly boundaries really for me I'm
looking at the watershed landscape
approach I'm sticking to satellites and
then satellites accuracy then yes the
red edge is very useful for measuring
nitrogen content when we're doing most
of this work up to 2013 we're using spot
imagery which only has red green blue
near for red and so we're not able to
measure nitrogen content now we can use
worldview 3 we can look at crop residue
I'm not praying about it but we have a
whole project that's looking at residue
intelligence and then yeah you can start
measuring the nitrogen percent nitrogen
content of Pro crops with sensors
especially with proximal sensors things
that you're flying over the field
maybe that's where we go with the next
five years in terms of the biomass
saturation I think that's always going
to saturate but being able to measure
the nitrogen content along with you know
that nitrogen content smartening varies
between percent and a half and five
percent depending on stage
thanks everybody over the rest of the
conference please you know
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu